[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily it is
still our office's position that 17 year
olds should not go armed with firearms
just off the heels of kyle rainhouse's
acquittal his friend dominique black
takes a plea deal and he's still here he
will probably outlive us all months
after this comment by prosecutors real
estate air and convicted killer robert
durst dies at age 78 plus any suggestion
that i am not complying with requests or
orders or demands or search warrants
about my phone
that's a lie the latest from alec
baldwin in the rush shooting
investigation and later the test came
back positive for human blood jurors are
shown a bloody act as chandler halderson
stands trial for the murder of his
parents law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin we have breaking news out of
california on the death of robert durst
but we'll get to that story in a moment
we begin with our top story out of
wisconsin the friend of kyle rinhaus who
bought an ar-15 for him enters into a
plea agreement with prosecutors law and
crime's angela levy is here with the
details of the plea anjanet
brian dominic black had faced two
felonies they were intent to sell a
dangerous weapon to someone younger than
18 resulting in a death now after
written house's acquittal black has
pleaded no contest to two county
ordinance violations of contributing to
the delinquency of a child dominica
black did not appear in court for this
hearing his attorney was there for him
and this happened in the courtroom of
judge bruce schroeder who presided over
kyle rittenhouse's trial now black was
dating kyle rittenhouse's sister in 2020
and described himself as and kyle as
being as close as brothers black said he
bought the ar-15 for kyle rittenhouse
before the protests in kenosha and that
they had an agreement that the gun would
stay at dominic black's house until kyle
rittenhouse turned 18. then on the night
of the shootings in august of 2020
written house in black had gone downtown
to kenosha to guard a car lot and we all
know what happened from there assistant
district attorney thomas wenger
explained why his office made this
agreement and major downgrading
it is a major downgrading of the charges
in the written house case this court
ruled that the
law
948.60 prohibiting possession of a
firearm by a minor did not apply to 17
year olds
that is a legal issue that could further
be appealed and briefed
i
personally disagree with the court's
ruling but i respect that ruling and i
believe that if this case were to go
forward in this court against mr black
that the
court would reach a similar legal
conclusion with regard to these two
charges
and dominic black you may recall
testified at kyle rittenhouse's trial
britton house's attorney asked black
about that on cross-examination
mr bigger can make a recommendation in
prison correct yes and you're hoping
that by you testifying he doesn't make a
recommendation correct
yes probation
there's no really assuming what i get
out of this
there's haven't been any promises made
i'm asking you what you're hoping
i'm hoping for whatever the best is i
get i don't know what it is okay
your attorney mr pat
he's met with you and mr binger and the
detectives yes
now assistant d.a thomas binger who
prosecuted kyle rittenhouse and who is
handling the dominic black case said
that he also agreed to this resolution
of the case because black was
cooperative through the written house
investigation and testified for the
state truthfully at the trial but it
appears by his comments in court that he
did not believe that the state was going
to get a conviction if they pressed
forward with taking dominic black to
trial brian
thanks angeannette joining today is
criminal defense attorney bernardo
villalona and terry austin barnard do
you think this is a strategic move as
angenette is telling us by the
prosecution because they didn't think
they could get a conviction
of black after reinhouse was acquitted
i have a problem with the decision by
the prosecutor i think the prosecutor
should have still gone forward in
regards to mr black because as of now
the way i see it is that there is no
accountability for mr black for
purchasing or serving as a straw
purchaser and getting this firearm that
was ultimately used to kill two other
individuals so i think it was an easy
way out uh i think the prosecution
should have researched the issue much
more because technically if you could
improve the case from the very beginning
then you should never charge mr black
outright
interesting terry bernardo's saying the
prosecution's going to should have taken
him to trial i'm asking almost in the
flip if rittenhouse got an acquittal
don't you think that black should have
gone to trial as well and tried to get
the same
i actually think the plea deal was a
good resolution i mean we know that you
know rittenhouse wasn't convicted and if
you go after black for having the gun
and purchased it and given it to written
house listen it's going to save time
it's going to save money not to go after
him and the fact that i think finger
made a good point the fact that dominic
black cooperated fully it had to be
difficult for him he and rittenhouse
were best friends kyle
sister was dating black and so i mean he
got on the stand he told the truth and
you know by playing it down i think it
was a good idea actually all right now
angenette did dominic black have a lot
of support from the public during all
this
you know it's interesting brian it's not
clear whether or not people in kenosha
were supportive of him but people on a
fundraising site certainly were his aunt
had set up this fundraising page on give
sengo and she set a goal of a hundred
thousand dollars for his legal fees and
as of this morning he had raised more
than seventy eight thousand dollars so
uh there was definitely some support for
him on some community forums online
whether or not there was widespread
support for him in the community of
kenosha
it's just not clear at this point
interesting but thank you for that that
interesting tidbit of the how much money
was raised for his legal service of
course something very similar that
happened with kyle harringhouse thank
you everyone now to arkansas as 19 kids
and counting janna duggar pleads guilty
to a third degree account of endangering
the welfare of a minor the star
originally pled not guilty when the news
of the case broke in december while
babysitting her younger siblings one of
the kids managed to get outside
unnoticed a neighbor saw the child and
called 9-1-1 which led to the charge
janet duggar was scheduled to appear in
court this week but the change of plea
resulted in an order to pay a fee of 880
the reality tv star's charge came on the
heels of her brother josh duggar being
convicted of downloading and possessing
child pornography a sentencing date for
josh duggar has not yet been set
still ahead actor alec baldwin takes to
social media to say he is cooperating
with the investigation into the shooting
on his russ movie set
but first big news out of california as
real estate air and convicted killer
robert durst dies months after being
given a life and sentence
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate lawn crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily only
months after a guilty verdict is handed
down real estate air and convicted
murderer robert durst dies at the age of
78 but as an appeal process has was not
yet complete at the time of his death
durst is legally not convicted of murder
after years of medical issues in a
recent coven 19 diagnosis the 78 year
old died of cardiac arrest on monday at
a hospital in california where he'd been
taken for a test this comes months after
his conviction in september of last year
for the 2000 murder of susan berman in
october he was sentenced to life in
prison ahead of that los angeles deputy
district attorney john lewin made a
startling comment about durst mortality
as his defense motion for a mishra
what this is is not a request for
mistrial what this really is is a
request for mr dirks to get a go home
get out of jail free card and never be
tried again and because there is no
current acute
situation that requires mr durst to be
hospitalized we are talking about
chronic conditions which may or may not
get better and again mr durst had very
serious cancer in 2005. he's still here
he will probably outlive us all
well then the trial continued resulting
in an eventual guilty verdict
prosecutors say durst killed berman
because she knew information about the
death of his first wife kathy mccormick
durst though a body has never been found
kathy derth went missing in 1982 and was
legally declared dead in 2017. durst was
durst has been a long time suspect in
the case and was indicted for her murder
last fall in a statement the mccormick
family said in part quote although
robert durst has died the ongoing
investigation into those who helped him
cover up the murder continues durst's
death comes just weeks before the 40th
anniversary of kathy durst's murder
philip dube explains what's next for
legal proceedings in the new york case
given durst's
death
no under california law no matter what
the cause of death is be it by you know
homicide suicide accident misfortune
a defendant whose criminal conviction is
not yet final on appeal
earns the right to have vacature of that
conviction and all further proceedings
and that includes abatement of any fines
that may have been imposed any
restitution orders payable to the victim
everything it just comes to a screeching
halt and i'm not going to say that the
defendant is posthumously acquitted but
it is the functional equivalent
so right now he does not stand convicted
and he cannot be posthumously prosecuted
in new york for the death of kathy so
that's going to also come to a halt so
right now there is nothing pending other
than the court of appeals awaiting the
um the lodging if you will of the death
certificate of robert durst so that they
can end the appeal and vacate the
conviction
all right let's bring in criminal
defense attorney bernardo villalona and
terry austin terry you followed the
durst trial from day one your thoughts
on his death so soon into his sentence
here's what i think brian he has eluded
conviction now three separate times
there's no question about it morris
black was killed and dismembered but he
didn't get convicted of killing morris
black he got convicted of dismembering
the body so he got away with murder
there he also was convicted for susan
berman but you just heard philip debate
talk about the fact that he's now dead
he can't be
charged posthumously with that he can't
be
having a conviction record now as far as
that's concerned and obviously for his
wife kathy durst he's not going to be
tried because he's now dead so that
family will never see justice so i
absolutely believe that robert durst
with his death has now gotten away with
murder three separate times now if
that's the case bernard how would you
measure justice in this case whereas as
terry has kind of outlined some of the
cases seem to be abated by death he
barely served a sentence on this case
after decades of being free i can't
imagine how john lewin is sleeping well
tonight these days
well as you can see with robert durst
robert durst guiding man without a
criminal record he has died as a man
that's gotten away with murder because
he has no convictions
in fact with lewin
he probably broke his tv once he heard
that robert durst died today because he
technically served only a couple of
months into his conviction and now we're
at where we started in the first place
without a criminal conviction robert
durst i feel bad for the families of
these deceased people because while they
made it to see a jury find him guilty as
to susan berman's death they didn't see
him carry out his sentence yeah and as
dubai said and terry echoed
technically
not convicted of any murders based on
california law and the posture in which
the case was on appeal so
it looks like in one way shape or form
durst kind of had one over at the end of
the day of eluding conviction
unfortunately not as much justice for
those families who have lost the loved
one
coming up on law and crime daily we head
to wisconsin as testimony continues into
week two in the chandler holliston
murder and dismemberment trial plus the
latest developments in the deadly
shooting on the russ movie set what
actor alec baldwin tells fans about his
involvement in the investigation
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
actor alec baldwin says he is
cooperating with a rush shooting
investigation even though the actor has
not turned over his cell phone to
investigators 42 year old
cinematographer helena hutchins was
killed and the director joel souza was
injured when baldwin fired a weapon on
set last october the gun was a prop but
had a live round in it in his first
interview after the shooting balton
claimed he never pulled the trigger
investigators conducted interviews after
the shooting which made them aware of
emails and text messages about the
production that led to a warrant for
balton's phone after the actor and his
lawyers refused to hand it over without
one the warren says the film's armorer
hannah gutierrez reid said baldwin was
not supposed to pull back the revolver's
hammer she says someone tried to
sabotage the set
over the weekend balton took to social
media to clear up what he calls lies
about his cooperation with the
investigation
any suggestion that i am not complying
with requests or orders or demands or
search warrants about my phone
that's a lie the best way
the only way
we can
honor
the death of helena hutchins is to find
out the truth
that's what i'm working toward insisting
on demanding
that the
organizations involved in this
investigation
uh do everything in their power
everything in their power to find out
what really happened that's all that
matters
all right back to break down the latest
in the rust investigation as criminal
defense attorney bernardo violona and
co-host terry austin terry if you were
baldwin's attorney would you be advising
him against speaking to the public like
this
i would absolutely advise him not to
speak to the public listen i taught a
public relations course at usc the last
thing you want to do when you're facing
charges is speak to the public because
you run the risk of saying too much and
you limit what your defenses could
possibly be if you say something that
will go against what you could claim
later so
one thing you can do is write a very
carefully written statement
that says listen i send my condolences
i'm going to cooperate fully but the
best thing to do is say nothing at all
yeah now bernarda how does a search
warrant for a phone work what can they
get out of their search
with the search warrant for a phone they
can get anything and everything so even
if items are deleted from your phone
when a search warrant is executed on the
phone itself it is dumping everything
text messages photos videos emails um if
you have instagram or social media
messages it will download all of that
usually a search warrant for a phone
ends up in thousands and thousands of
pages of information including your
search history on google as well as
internet searches as well
i will see where this continues more
investigation and warrants being issued
in this the rust investigation when we
come back week two kicks off in the
chandler holder central in wisconsin
investigators share physical evidence in
the case including some personal items
of the victims
[Music]
welcome back to long crime daily week
two of the chandler holders and trial
resumes in wisconsin as jurors get a
first hand look at evidence recovered
during the investigation prosecutors say
23-year-old chandler holderson murdered
his parents fifty-year-old bart and
fifty-three-year-old krista halderson in
july 2021. after that they say holderson
cut up their bodies and attempted to
burn their remains in the family
fireplace halderson is also accused of
scattering parts of their bodies around
southern wisconsin on monday morning
several investigators took the stand
detailing what evidence was collected
during the initial investigation deputy
greg leatherbury showed jurors a bloody
axe that was found in the halterson
family garage
213 is a photograph
of the axe that i collected
from
the garage
and just to
back up this axe was
kind of hidden behind some boards
it was something that you had to look
to see i wouldn't say it was was hidden
it was it was concealed uh by its
placement but if you had the right angle
you could
you could see it was there
all right
so exhibit 214 can you please describe
it
exhibit 214 is a photograph showing
staining that is on
the
area of where the axe head
and the handle of the ax
come together this red staining is
consistent in an appearance
with that of blood
there's a biohead is there to stick it
on sticker on there
again
because of the reddish-brown staining
the reddish-brown staining that is on
the axe is human blood i tested it with
the phenolphthalein test the presumptive
positive
i then followed with the hexagon obti
test
to
determine if it's human blood or not and
the test came back positive for human
blood
how would you rate this investigation
was it thorough or can you find that he
holds it
i haven't seen any holes in this
investigation yet all all lanes all
lanes and all signs lead to this
defendant as being the person culpable
for this horrific death of his own
parents it's sick how much things that
we've seen that this man was capable of
doing it's like a movie a horror movie
that i've never seen probably jason and
freddie all put together in one scene
now tara we we've got all these bits and
pieces that we're obviously collecting
from this investigation how do you think
the prosecution will use this evidence
in their summation
you know it's interesting brian this is
all circumstantial evidence they found
blood on the axe they found blood or
they had particles on the shoes from the
area where he was walking and all of
that demonstrates that he was at the
scene of this crime that he was involved
and i think during summation we're going
to hear the prosecution talk about
how gruesome this murder was like
bernard said it is worse than a horror
movie he not only killed his parents but
he chopped them up with that axe and
that axe is in the room with these
individuals who are going to be judging
the case and their mind is thinking
about how gruesome all of this was and
the fact that this is a son doing this
to his parents it really does show that
he is a
coal-blooded heartless killer it's bad
enough that he killed them for whatever
reason and nothing was justified but
that he dismembered their bodies and
tried to hide it is horrible so this is
going to really i think have an impact
on the jury yeah and from what you two
are saying so far it seems like there's
quite enough information to do that as
well thank you and thank you for joining
us here at law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as you discuss justice in
america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you